you look gorgeous thank you very much  tell me about that beautiful it's bomb  man it's 40 phone it's 40 pounds and I'm  just living my dream in it great thank  you let's talk about girls yeah please  Bella join us okay I'm kind of freaking  out it is a very sad thing to end a show  like this but I feel very good about the  way that we're leaving things and I feel  good about the way that we're wrapping  it up it's just tricky because like how  do you say goodbye to all of these  characters that people have gotten to  know that we've been playing for all  these years and say goodbye to each  other like the girls ourselves are very  sad but we'll get through it how do you  I think you just stay in touch i think  is the most basic like obvious reason i  think you just kind of make sure you  don't lose track of each other  you